okay about brass
i got you two i couldn't get the brand
that you wanted ari's ex-husband leandro
came to ethiopia bearing gifts including
some new bras for ari
yes
bras
if you don't like them it's fine
i can get uh the good ones next time
awesome oh billiam's face says it all
i'm surprised you still you don't forget
he says her size like him i just and i'm
surprised he's still smiling
[Music]
hey andra
this was binium's first time meeting
leandro in person and overall
it was awkward i was very confused oh
goodness let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio hey
andra
we finally got to get a full look at
ari's ex-husband leandro and see how
they interact with each other but she's
so excited she's writing she's hey hi hi
again like something just blah blah
during this episode ari also revealed
that up until she met binyam and got
pregnant she thought she would
eventually get back with leandro which
just confirms that there might be some
unfinished business here but before we
get into that you never wear like shorts
like a dress when you wear shorts you
always you always want me to wear a
short dress arie made sure she was
looking real cute prior to picking up
leandro from his hotel which had been
him feeling some type of way this is
what he do is like
your nail like for
leandro no baby i want to look nice so
you look like extremely nice today yes
wow i'm flattered that you're so jealous
where's your ring at the nail salon
binyam also noticed that ari didn't have
on her engagement ring which she said
she left at home by an accident maybe
you should for me like for myself like
am i ashamed of you yeah i'm not ashamed
of you baby
the day that my ex happens to be coming
i happen to forget my ring
it looks bad
benim assumed that she didn't put on the
ring because the ring is cheap according
to him it's worth less than one us
dollar
don't look at me i'm not saying nothing
i guess it's a symbolism that counts
right
maybe
okay tell me what's going on are you
frustrated
i don't know why you should do this well
billion went home and got the ring so
she could put it on now let's fast
forward to bingham and leandro coming
face to face welcome to africa
thank you
hey
that hug was the first of many awkward
moments
he doesn't look like he came from
america and speaking of first bingham
shared his first impression of leandro
and said he looks like a nerdy guy which
i agree but i personally don't think
looking like a nerd is a bad thing
at least he's not out here trying hard
to be cool are you excited to see where
i live where we live how do you say yes
oh oh all for learning i'm hurrying in
one week
maybe you can come live with us
did you catch that maybe you can come
live with us
ari said maybe you can come live with us
then you'll learn
[Music]
as you'll see throughout this recap
there are a few moments where ariella
randomly says something that makes the
situation even more uncomfortable
check out when leandra was introducing
himself to baby abby
listen to what she says come on you want
to see
yeah move your ankle
you could have had a baby like this but
you didn't you missed out she's so quiet
now
yeah are you really comfortable with
andrea why are you so comfortable with
andre look at benyam still trying to
keep up that smile
the interesting part about it is i don't
think she's doing it to be hurtful the
comments are just slipping out you could
have a baby like this but you didn't you
missed out which is why i am not for
hanging out with my partner and my ex at
the same time nope
it's too many gears to switch for me
i would really have to watch my mouth
okay he wants to try the the glasses
oh
wow he's so quiet now the tension was so
thick in the room benyam was over here
fumbling the glasses
and he also seemed salty about leandro
holding his baby which i would be too
leandro
having a fortunate butter i don't think
so he's happy like when he's hugged him
the first time
we can help him arms or father
but he's doing a good job at keeping us
cool don't say don't say
don't sit down baby cool
do you think you will be able to keep
your composure
because i would have said something a
long time ago right here maybe you can
come live with us
can come live with us
anyway let's get into the gifting
portion of their day aka when leandro
pulls out the bras but he's only been
here an hour and i can already tell
there's some passive aggressive tension
beneath the surface
i get
anyways oh
that was uncomfortable
okay so you want me to catch your stuff
leandro opens his suitcase full of gifts
and things ari asked him to bring you
know you can't get a lot of stuff in
eugenia
the best
thing yeah that's mine too leandro gets
her toothpaste and then he pulls out the
oh okay about brass
i got you two i couldn't get the brand
that you wanted
but they are
about the same thing i don't know
you make your judgment
if you don't like them it's fine
i can get
the good ones next time awesome
no worry my girlfriend picked him me
binium's face right here is priceless
and his girlfriend
what
don't tell me there's another woman
involved in this it's your saiso
i'm surprised you still you don't forget
he says her size like images ari
eventually explained what was going on
here which is that she's breastfeeding
and she needs new bras so leandro
brought them because she couldn't find
any good ones in ethiopia to be honest
at first i didn't think him bringing her
bras was a big deal but
then i thought about it
if my man had an ex who gave him boxers
or even an undershirt you're giving
those back
you're not wearing those around me the
andrew is timothos
felt like leandro bringing ari such an
intimate item was inappropriate and says
he doesn't accept it but he did accept
the speakers that leandro gave him oh
she's for music yeah music stuff and
thank you
and that is all for santa claus for
for now thank you so much for everything
just
yeah next time i could get you some
things from martial arts because i know
that
is much cheaper in the u.s and it's
easier to find this stuff this screen
grab right here says a thousand words
ari looks like she's in awe of leandro
and binyam looks like his pride is shot
and he's stressed
you two like guys your relationship is
wonderful but then bingham asks the
question that we all want to know
which is something ari has been asked
before but i don't think we ever got a
clear answer i think having binyam and
leandro to answer in front of this time
made a difference why are you do as tina
just together why we broke up we never
actually broke up it was i just never
came home yeah it was like a decaying uh
experience i told andrew that i would
move with him to indiana
but then
i decided i wanted to travel the world i
know that lander had it in his mind that
i would come back
in the back of my mind i also thought we
would eventually get back together again
that's why i didn't want to break up
with him because i was sure this was
just like a hiatus
and then i met vinnie
she was married to leandro from when she
was 19. to when she was 29.
those are prime years so she wanted to
explore herself outside of being in a
relationship with him and she's
definitely doing that just based off of
the tears that are about to flow down
her face
i'm not sure if she's truly at peace
with the decision she made because i
didn't want to lose you i wanted to keep
the option open maybe that if
if this new life that i was thinking
about didn't work out
i could go back to the life i was
comfortable with which is that because i
didn't deserve that and i'm sorry i
actually feel super bad about it
i was very confused
i don't i don't hold grunches that makes
me sad because i don't know i just feel
like a person you would think that
because they are best friends and they
talk all the time that they would have
had this conversation before now but
obviously not even still why have it in
front of binium their day together from
what we saw seemed like ari was
remembering why she fell for leandro in
the first place and binium was just
there
constantly trying to hold on to that
smile it's going to be interesting to
see how they continue to juggle these
emotions ari i don't know how you're
doing it girl my heart goes out to you
come on
next week leandro and benny get physical
leonardo i think
is
[Music]
benjamin he said stop isn't that what
slapping the floor means he was really
choking them in
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time